.
Hi, everybody.
How you doing?
I guess you guys all.
Oh, you're great.
You can chat over and back.
Great, great, great.
Oh, great to see you all.
How you doing?
We can chat away while people are coming in.
If you have anything to say, feel free.
Hi, Ren.
Hi, Scott.
Hi, Brenda.
Feel free to chat away until we get started.
It's summer here.
The clock just changed in Dublin, in Ireland.
We just had our clock change.
So we always say there's a grand stretch in the evening.
So today's the first evening with a grand stretch in the evening.
And I don't know.
I'm assuming there's some Irish people, some American people, maybe.
But for any of you not here anyway, it's amazing.
You guys had the clock change in America a few weeks ago.
I think there's always a little bit of a staggeredness.
I missed some of my lessons this week because of it.
You always have to keep an eye on it then a few weeks.
Original sound is going on.
Hang on.
There it is.
Okay.
We have that sorted.
I'm just going to check the waiting room.
Okay.
So I think somebody's letting them in.
Caitlin's probably letting them in.
So that's grand.
I'll keep an eye anyway.
So we'll get started and people can join.
You know, I want to make the most of the time.
If there's anyone that has anything specific that they want out of this workshop, throw it
into the chat there.
More than happy to kind of be specific with people's kind of wishes and things like that.
I'm going to start.
I'm not going to spend too much time on theory kind of things.
I want to get into it practically.
And kind of, I was kind of thinking maybe just of looking at actual like snippets of tunes
and actually kind of figuring out how to do some melodic variation within those.
So that's what I think would be the best.
If that sounds good to you guys, that's what I was thinking of doing.
Yeah.
Yeah, good, good, good.
Um, anyone got anything to say there?
No?
All good.
Okay.
So just a quick kind of a thing.
I guess most of you probably know what melodic variation is, but like what, you know, what
is it?
I am for me.
It's kind of a little bit.
I mean, variation, ornamentation, melodic variation, tune versions, that kind of thing.
You know, what is what?
And there's all blurred.
I think there's blurred lines.
But for the purpose of this, isn't that what Miley Cyrus says?
But for the, for the purpose of this workshop, I think that it's just admit somebody in there.
Um, I think that, you know, ornamentation involves technique.
I think with these melodic variations, there's actually no technique involved.
Um, there's no special skill, um, to be able to do a melodic variation.
It's just varying, um, the melody.
And I, I have a kind of a, a little kind of a system of how to put in ornamentation.
I almost view melodic variation as a kind of ornamentation.
But ornamentation is also a kind of variation.
So it's really like what, you know, what came first kind of thing.
But I have a little kind of a ladder, an ornamentation ladder system that I, I try to implement sometimes for students.
Um, when, when trying to get them to put ornamentation in and goes from your, your lowest rung is your easiest form of ornamentation.
And, you know, which would be different depending on what you find easy compared to somebody else, you know, somebody else might find this thing easy.
Somebody else might not know how to do this thing.
So it's not part of their ladder or anything yet.
But I, when I was starting off with that little system, it's just a simple little system that I have.
Um, I kind of, um, thought that melodic variation or what I sometimes call it long notes, short notes, my own terminology.
Nobody would, nobody else would know what you were talking about if you said that.
But long notes, short notes is finding the long notes and making them into shorter notes or looking at short, a group of short notes and figuring out how to throw in a long note.
That's really kind of what melodic variation is to me.
Um, the, that's the basics of it.
Um, I thought that that was going to be a real easy thing for people because there's not an actual skill, you know, you don't have to know how to do a cut.
You don't know how to do, know how to do a crann.
Um, do you know what I mean?
It's just literally very, this melody, but actually people, my students, I discovered a lot of people find it quite hard.
Um, and it is basically in my mind, it's maths debate.
You know, the, the, the kind of this, the kind of, um, small, uh, on dramatic, you know, kind of little, nice, tasty, little variations.
Not the, the big, crazy, like kind of almost like a jazz variation.
That's gone, you know, the tune is kind of unrecognizable.
But I think in Irish music, more of those little variations there, they're kind of like a little bit like maths.
You know, it's, it's maths with, with feeling is what I always say about, uh, music.
Um, so, um, that's kind of, that's what I would think.
Has anyone any questions about that before we, uh, maybe get stuck into some tunes or anything to add to that?
Oh, and did anyone put anything in chat?
Nothing yet in chat, I don't think.
And nobody waiting to get in.
Okay, good.
Um, I have one thing to say.
Yeah.
I guess for me, melodic variation is difficult because I've learned the tune with sort of muscle memory.
And so, and, and, you know, I'm just getting to the point now where I'm kind of following, I'm playing the tune as I'm hearing it in my head.
And I'm assuming that's kind of where the, the, uh, melodic variation starts to come in.
Yeah.
It's hard, isn't it?
Like, you know, you're, you're, it's the, that's the thing.
Um, are we, are we mostly concertina players or are there non-concertina players?
Uh, any, a, a, a whistle there I see.
Yeah.
Um, I think it doesn't matter either way.
Um, just with concertina especially, um, I feel like that kind of, I play it this way thing.
You have to be very careful because, uh, of, of the, the variety of ways there are to play the bloody thing on that bloody instrument.
Um, so that's the problem, a blessing and a curse.
I always call it.
You could, there's so many different ways to play it, but then when it comes to melodic variation, if you have been kind of keeping yourself adaptable with how you play it on the instrument, and then the melodic variation is probably easier.
Um, so, uh, um, yeah, like it, I suppose it's that thing of getting stuck, but really, I suppose if I, if I look at this now, I, hopefully this will
be helpful for that actually, Scott.
So I'll have, uh, let's see if this is helpful with that just because it does, a lot of it, I find when I'm teaching it, I never learned it this way.
And I'm teaching it kind of going, Oh, I would just do this kind of naturally, you know, like there's nearly no way I would ever play the same phrase twice in a tune in a row, unless it was on purpose.
I nearly couldn't do it, you know, it's almost impossible.
So what I get some of my students to do, like say for instance, now there will be some ornamentation in this, but I'm, I am trying to stick to melodic variation in this, but it's gonna overlap a touch.
Well, let, we will try and really focus on that topic, but for instance, the tune, and you don't have to know these tunes, um, in order for it to, to, to, to, you know, to be, to understand it.
But there's, you know, a tune called, um, the Glantin, um, and it's, it, you know, it's one of these reels that's an A, B, you play the first part once, the second part once.
And, um, so the, and most of those, the first part at least is generally four bars repeated.
So there's re they're really quite repetitive, you know, and this tune, like, you know,
How's that sound by the way?
Any problems?
It's good.
Okay.
So that's the tune.
It's basically that twice.
Exact same thing twice.
And what I find really helps with putting in melodic variation there is, find three different ways to play.
Because that's the bit that's repeating, isn't it?
D, G, B, G.
You know, find a few different ways to play it.
And then every time you come to it, play it different and go around in circles.
I have my students do that for weeks and weeks.
And go around in circles.
And when you suddenly, suddenly you find yourself bored and it won't be for a while, that's when, you know, okay, I'm comfortable with this now.
So it could be just a long D. So the first time, always let the tune exist, let the tune be.
You need to know what the tune is before you vary it.
That was it once.
Now we have it again.
A long D.
And then we have it again.
So it's three times in four bars.
Do you know what I mean?
That's what I mean about these repeating phrases.
When you're going looking in, I mean, we've jumped in quite quickly here, but when, when you're going looking for a place, where do you, where do you put the melodic variation is a question, I suppose.
This is where you find the bit that repeats the bit.
That's like, oh God, am I like, you know, am I going to play this over and over again the same?
No, this is the bit you want to vary.
And you could just find that one part, one, there'll be one in most tunes, there'll be one obvious thing like that.
And you go, okay, I'm going to go in there, look at that, how many ways can I play that?
Outside the scope of this, this workshop, you'll be looking at all your ornamentation as well.
In this workshop, like melodic variation in that is the long D.
So D, the notes are D, G, B, G.
Right.
So now we're going to get rid of the G, the first G, D, G, B, G is going to become D, D, B, G.
So it's maths, the D is now worth the D and the G.
And actually, that's a good first step.
You've got three times of this repeating phrase in four bars.
So first, what you're trying to do is get your brain reacting to what's coming.
It's like a video game.
Here comes this boring bit again, you know, what am I going to do?
It's like, oh God, let's do it, but your brain isn't maybe there yet, depending on what stage
you're at.
So what I get people to do is maybe for eight bars, maybe six times you do the melody.
Or maybe you're going to three times, because you do it for four bars.
I hope that makes sense.
If anybody doesn't understand what I'm saying there, but yeah, it happens three times in
four bars, one, two, three.
That's your four bars, yeah?
So the first three times, you just do the melody.
The second, put in that long note.
It's too quick to be changing yet.
You're not comfortable with it yet.
So do that three times.
Okay, now let's figure out another way.
Well, we have turn the second low D, the second beat of that long low D into a high D.
And then, you know, when you get bored with that going round and round in circles and everything
is like in the proper tempo.
You're playing it with a metronome maybe and then, okay, let's see, can we do it every
second thing?
Do them twice in a row, which gives you kind of your going over, you're moving them along
different four bar kind of sections, you know, you're kind of, and then until, once you're
doing that melodic variation, every bar, then you're kind of doing it, you know, you're
kind of going, and of course, there's more than three ways to do it.
So you start bringing in other ways and you just don't ever go to the second part.
Just play it.
It's a great tune for that.
I use this tune a lot.
I probably thought it to you, Scott.
And then you just go round and round in circles and start to be, just be able to react to
the thing that's coming up to you because that's what it really is.
You know, when you get used to it, that's really what it is, is kind of just, yeah, I'm just
going to check the questions.
And if anyone has any questions or suggestions about that.
So to work on some variation when learning a tune, yeah, it is good to work on it when learning
the tune.
It's different schools of thought.
I know that like Mary Bergen teaches the variations and the ornamentation while people
are learning the tune.
I don't, I really feel like, and who am I to disagree with Mary Bergen, but like it's
a different instrument.
But like for me, I'm kind of like, if you can't play the tune, basically, I don't see
if you've any business putting any ornamentation or variations into it, you know?
Maybe that's, maybe I should rethink it, maybe, maybe not ornamentation, but maybe variation
is good to put into it while you're learning it.
And that might make it just easier for you rather than it be like Scott said, like, you
know, you're stuck in the way you're playing and not stuck, but you play it from muscle memory.
And then putting this variation in is kind of, yeah, it's another way to think about it
for sure.
And that tune is called the Glantan.
Hang on till I write it down.
It's not the road to Glantan, it's just the Glantan, I believe.
And, oh, funny spelling there, but yeah.
So now, when I try varying a tune on the fly, sometimes diverge a little too much from the
melody and lose myself, gag it back to the tune.
Embarrassing.
Yes.
Absolutely.
Happens us all.
So, you know, I think that work that I've just suggested in the Glantan, that kind of
thing is really valuable groundwork to put in at home so that you get used to being able
to do these things on the fly.
Doing them on the fly, like it's kind of, it's kind of hard.
It's kind of a, you know, a bit of, it's kind of advanced moves, you know, especially if
you're in a session and you're maybe going a bit faster or not quite the swingy rhythm
you like to play at, then things are just harder, you know, and you could maybe practice
your, I think keep it, keep it to less things, you know, do one thing per tune first.
I mean, that's, you know, set realistic goals, life lessons here on Tune Supply.
Set realistic goals, you know, do one thing in several tunes, do one thing in one tune,
then do one thing in several tunes, then do one thing in each part.
Do you know what I mean?
And it's just building it up like that gives you, gives you a, a more, more chance of success
and you'll be delighted with yourself, you know?
So yeah, so getting yourself back to the tune, I, oh, the other thing that I've been doing,
it happens with that, with that comment from Karen, and you know, when you lose it and
you can't get back, I find, especially with concertina, but I think this applies to most
instruments, that when people start getting out of control, they start playing harder and
pumping harder and, and, you know, becoming more tense, and on whatever instrument it is,
fingers and bows and whatever become more tense.
And I do think that I've tried to train myself on, I play really bad guitar and I've tried
to kind of train myself to respond by quietening down and, you know, softening rather than harder.
It makes it sound so much worse when you go like, and scraping like, oh, I'm lost and I'm
making sure everybody hears it, you know?
So trying to just kind of react that way is really good, you know?
Could we create a list of types of variations from simple to more complex?
Well, you see, Richard, what you're talking about is ornamentation there.
So I'm not going to go to, like, octaves are ornamentation in my mind, you know?
They are obviously a variation because the word vary, you know?
But here I'm looking at melodic variations.
So I am going to go through to some tunes now because we've spent maybe 15 minutes there.
So we've an hour or so left to look at actual tunes.
I am happy to take tune suggestions, but I'm going to start with a few of my own ideas.
Because, you know what, I used to play tunes, there's tunes that, you know, you've been playing
this music since you were five, you develop different relationships with tunes.
Like there's tunes that I used to hate, that I love now.
And you just kind of realize, oh, and some of them are tunes that are just so repetitive.
But now when I see a repetitive tune, I'm like, oh, this is a tune that I can put loads
of ornamentation, it's like wide open for all of it.
The battering ram.
Okay, we'll have a look at the battering ram in a while.
So it leaves it wide open.
One of the most repetitive tunes that I know, and the most boring ones, is the, we call it
the Superman jig, but Bill Hart's jig, because it's, it sounds like Superman.
You know?
But it's, that's Bill Hart's jig, or affectionately known as the Superman jig.
I do have a blackboard behind me here, and I don't have an S on my computer keyboard actually,
so I'm going to use a Z, oh dear.
I have four computers though, this is just the one, all the other ones have an S.
So, so Bill Hart's, just looking at that, like, you know, if you take the melody, I tried,
GoFundMe to buy you an S, I tried to get an S, there is no way to get an S on this.
I copy and paste my S's.
So, if we wrote down, I mean, now we're getting to the point, okay, what is the actual melody?
Is it like the, oh, I, I, I, for simplicity's sake, I'm just going to say that the melody
is all those long notes.
You know, so there's loads of long notes there, but it, it's not really a huge jump.
I mean, maybe I won't go into this one too much, it's too simple.
So, you know, it's not a huge jump to be going.
So, I got rid of every single long note there.
None of it was, and there was absolutely no skill involved.
Zero.
All I did was the maths.
Now, if any, I mean, that, it's pretty simple there, but I, I won't go through it all.
But just so that you have it, I mean, you know, I, I think you, you probably get that.
But just because it is a workshop, God, how am I going to, how am I going to do this?
This is going to be fun.
Um, maybe I should have moved that chair.
Okay.
Now, I wonder, can you see that blackboard?
I think you can.
Yeah.
Maybe I'm going to bring this closer.
Okay.
So, and I will, I'll bring it even closer actually.
And, so the, if we go D and I, and so we're in groups of three because it's a jig.
D, D, A, A.
So I'll just deal with like literally little phrases like that.
This is word two.
These are word three.
This is two, three.
You know, so it just becomes D, E, D, A, G, A, B.
And the same the whole way through.
So that's the absolute basics of it.
You know, I think you can all probably do that.
And D, D, A, D, I mean, then it's kind of like, well, what else could you do?
You know, that's a melodic variation.
You know, you could do, you know, you could do chords and you can do octaves and you can do,
but they're not melodic variation as I see it.
So for D, so.
I would do a low A instead of the E there.
That's another variation.
D, A, D.
And there's where your music theory comes in a little bit.
You could, it's good to have a little mild bit of music theory for this.
So, you know, we're in the key of D something or other.
And just to know that the notes, the chords in the key and the notes in the chords.
So just a quick, I know most people know that, but the chords in the key.
Now this is kind of D mixolydian.
So it doesn't really follow that.
But in D major, D minor, it's D, it's one, four and five, D, G and A.
If anyone doesn't understand that, that's fine.
And this is going to be D's and C's because it's what's called mixolydian.
It goes from the D to the C to the, isn't it?
Or it's modal or something.
Anyway, it doesn't matter too much.
But if we, the main thing is the chord of D is one, three and five, D, F and A.
And so D and A, you know, this is basically a D sound.
This long D, D is a long sound of D.
And so the low A is going to work because that's part, that note is part of the chord.
And so that's low D, E, D, D, A, D, probably D, C, D is going to work.
It's going to not, a note above the main note and a note below, usually are options.
So we have D, E, D, D, C, D.
I don't like it as much, but there's no denying it works, you know?
So now we have like one, two, three and D, C, D, four melodic ways of playing it.
And none of them are rocket science, you know?
But it's just a case of getting your brain to start thinking like that.
That's all it is, you know?
So now if I, now if I go through the whole tune with this phrase.
You know what I mean?
Immediately, immediately it sounds more interesting to the ear.
And it's not, we've done nothing.
We've done next to nothing, you know?
And all the rest of the notes I kept the same.
So really don't, I suppose one message here is don't get bogged down in technique.
It's so, it's so, there's such little things that can make.
And then if we do the same to this one.
So we have AGA.
I actually, I really, like this topic I find really interesting, you know?
But like, so AGA, I wonder what an A, I think this one's going to be harder.
I don't think an A, so we said the note below and the note above the main note.
So if the main note here was D, E is above it and C is below it.
Here we have A, G is below it and we know that works.
But will B work?
It works, but it's kind of iffy because there's a B coming soon after it melodically.
So we have D, you'd want to be very sure of which note is the note that has the beat,
you know?
So that kind of thing.
A is a note in the chord of D, D, F and A, we said one, three and five.
So I'm figuring that a low D might work here.
So A, B, A, yeah, sure.
And A, D, A is going to work.
Because that, and it's, again, they're all going to work with varying levels of,
you know, taste is a factor.
You might not like it as much.
You kind of start to, a lot of melodic variation, you get a feel for what works and what doesn't
work.
So now, now we have a scenario where we have four ways to play this and four ways to play
this without ever touching ornamentation yet.
We haven't brought in crayons or rolls or cuts or, do you know what, or harmony notes.
So now we get to mix and match.
So we're really in a good position here.
We go.
And so we do mix and match.
We do this one with this one and this one with this one.
And, you know, that's really increases the number of ways you can play it.
And it's kind of like, holy moly.
Like, do you actually need to do anything else at that point?
You know, it's just so much going on then.
And for your brain, like I was struggling there a little bit, like just playing that through,
going, oh God, which one am I going to do with that one next?
You know, and you know, there's, there's a lot going on there.
So, um, I, I, I look like that's, but you're, I will get a little bit more complicated than
this as well.
But, uh, just kind of, it's a good introduction to kind of what actually can be done with so
little, um, of anything.
So does anyone have any questions about that?
Um, I can move on to maybe the second part of the tune as well.
Um, but is that clear?
And is there any, if there's any part of that, like, like you were complete, like on, what
is she talking about?
Please don't hesitate to ask, you know?
Brenda, um, I was wondering if, um, uh, after some practice, it ever comes easier to you
because right now looking at this, it seems like you have to very intense, intently think
about, you know, what are the options.
And so almost you sort of map out, like, these are the different options.
And this is, then I think about where to put them in.
No, it becomes natural.
I mean, you know, you guys, I presuming most of you are adult learners, um, you know, this
immersion, I never had to think about it, you know, ever.
I only think about it when I'm teaching.
Um, I think about it in a, in a, like, uh, this is the whole thing I think about when
I'm playing traditional Irish music.
If I'm in a session, this is all I'm thinking about.
That's what, this is what it's all about.
Like, to me, this is where, once you get beyond the, once you get to a certain point
of being able to play okay, this is it, to me.
You know, this is what you're in the session.
You're hearing the person beside you go.
Like, for instance, Sean Clawsey, a good friend of mine in Boston.
Like, there's a tune called The Boys of the Town.
And Sean is the best crack for playing a session.
And he's just, he's got such lift in his music.
And once, and you're sitting beside him and you're like, and he, he did this thing.
And he did, so the tune is.
And he did, this is where you're going into the big jazzy, but it's not crazy, but I would
never think of it.
And he just did.
So yeah, your ending point, you're landing on that low G.
And now I, I never play that tune without doing that, you know, but nobody else I've
ever heard doing it, you know, or the likes of playing with Michelle.
So this is, this is what I'm sitting in a session, listening to the other person.
And what, on the other instruments, it's not going to constantly play fiddle.
And, and you're kind of like picking up, you know, that's the freedom of it and the fun.
And maybe to have a few drinks and it's even better.
And, you know, but the, another one is Michelle O'Brien.
I played with her a lot and I, she plays old John's jig.
And so the very, the, she puts in a great one again, a big, another big one kind of thing.
And here she, she, instead of that, she does.
Now, you could say that's three cramps, but you could do that without cramps.
You could do, you know, and that, so now you've got, you know, it's so different, but you're, you're at your landing point.
What I always say when you're doing any ornamentation, but variation as well.
It's Cotton Eye Joe.
Where did you come from?
Where did you go?
Where are you going?
Where have you come from?
Where is that last note before this variation is happening?
Root yourself in that.
Figure out your variation on its own.
And then where are you going?
What's the next note out of that variation?
Out of the changed thing.
This is ornamentation or variation.
This will work.
Make sure that you're able and this will help with, oh, I'm in the session and I do a big variation.
I get lost and I can't find my way back.
That rooting yourself.
I'm not finished answering your question, Lulu.
I just got waylaid.
But yeah, so all of that is interesting, but the answer to your question, the fuller answer
or the end of the answer to your question, Lulu, is I think that all of that work is really important to do
because then, especially as adult learners, I think that then it starts to bring it in naturally.
I'm working with students at the moment with adults.
I teach a lot of adult students and I'm working with quite a few of them on trying to get into that natural way of being able to do ornamentation and variations.
And these exercises, you won't always have to do that.
You know, this music of ours is not that complicated.
Like, you know, we're not playing crazy keys.
We're in D, G and A and E minor and A minor.
You know what I mean?
So it crosses over.
We're playing mostly jigs and reels.
So it crosses over, but it's definitely worth putting that work in for a while.
And the reward then is you see it start to cross over and it starts to become easier.
But it can be a bit boring and it can be hard if you don't know how or where to go, like how to go about it, I suppose, on your own.
So, um, so yeah, um, that answered that question.
Yeah.
Anybody else?
Um, okay.
I might look at the second part of this real quick.
Um, or yeah, then move on to a real, um, or the battering ram.
We could look at two.
Let's see.
So, um, the blackboard isn't very big.
So there's not room for many phrases, but, um, it's kind of cool to do just, uh, so the second part,
so the second part of that tune is so boring.
Oh God, because it's just such a dose of, it's basically, it's basically some long notes and all that stuff that we're bored of already from the first part.
Do you know what I mean?
Cause, cause it's.
Here's the second part.
And again.
It's two bars.
It's awful.
You know?
So you have, like, oh my God.
You really have to vary it.
Um, and I'm going to take off my jumper cause it's warm here.
Um, so that second part is actually even more interesting.
So you've got, I'm going to write it.
I'm going to write it smaller.
So you have D and if you can't see it, um, I think Caitlin gives me your emails after or whatever.
C, A, B, A, G, A, B, C.
So it's C natural.
So long, short, long, short, da, da, da, da, da, da.
Okay.
And it does that four times basically.
You know?
The long, short, long, short happen four times.
So actually what I can do is make it bigger.
Because what we'll be looking at is the D, B, C, A.
That's the repeating bit.
So find your, if you're looking for a system, a logical system, which is how my brain works,
find a, find the repeating bit.
And this is it.
D, B, C, A.
Now, obviously we've got, we can fill in this.
D to B, there's an obvious note in between.
Have a think what it is.
Of course, it's going to be C.
D, C, B.
C to A, the note that lies in between is B.
C, B, A.
Okay.
So now you have kind of, because then you can mix and match these two, you know?
And, and that way, and that way, and that way, and that way, you know?
So that all already opens it up.
Can you see properly?
Yeah?
Okay.
So now let me get the concertina because you can do so much by looking at it.
That's melodic variation.
You know?
That's just melody.
D.
C.
Dленas and D.
D.
Tina but let's have a little look oh yeah the obvious one is on some
instruments you can double up D D B C C A so just two high D's see see again
could be instrument specific maybe I you know I don't see why not
you can go to the D the whole time that's still no skill there's no technique
there that's still just melodic variation you know and again some
instruments I can't imagine a fiddle would do it but you know definitely D D
no D no D C no D no D so these are all you know easy very obvious variations
instrument specific variations to you know oh that's a bit of a weird one but
it's it could work on many instruments and let me just play it through and see
if any other ones come yeah I mean you can hang on you can hang on to a
note so say you made the C I got rid of the A and hold the C for three so now
you could do D B D D B D B I'll play it in a minute and then C for the whole lot
needs you have to have attitude to do that you can't just play a little kind of
beige C you have to play it and mean it you know if you're gonna hang on to notes
you need to mean it so now this becomes
swell your notes you know kind of leave it hanging so I'll put it in it I'll
play the tune a bit and put it in later into the tune so I'll play them all
you know conversely you can do it with the high D and it's literally just it's
actually simpler it's getting rid of notes you know but I would never do a D C
you'd have to pair them up with with three notes and the other one you know
so yeah so does that make make sense there we we still are on melodic
variation we haven't gone to ornamentation at all and there's quite a
lot there I think you'll agree right and it's again it's not rocket science it's
just trying to get your brain thinking that way and so and any questions there
or will I move on maybe to a real but the B part of it's not useful in this I mean
do you know what I mean that's the repeat so there I went and find the repeating
part so in the four bars of it it doesn't have a repeating thing and so everything
repeats the second time around that four part four bars so the only thing really
it's not quite a useful learning or teaching exercise for in that so it's B
D D C sharp D so divide it into groups of four it's B D D C sharp D E F that's the
two groups of four and so then it's just like oh just change the C sharp to an E
or change it to a B and a low low G on concertina some of these things work and
they might not work on other things so that's the kind of em this it's me again it's not quite
a useful one so I'll I'll move on any other suggestions or questions yeah could you play
that the bill hearts jig through yeah of course yeah completely and then that helps me a lot to
be able to hear it back and yeah I'll play it and I'll play it through and try and stick to
melodic variations as opposed to as opposed to ornamentation so I'm gonna play it I'll play
the first part straight and I'm gonna get to the second part I'll play the second part straight as well
I'm gonna play it well
Thank you.
This old long notes, short notes, like, you know, in this tune, we're looking at long notes and we're most, like, we started out with a long D and everything else really is making that, those long notes into short notes, apart from these attitude ones at the end where we're creating an even long note.
When you get short notes and you turn them into long notes, then that opens up space, in concertina anyway, and I think in other instruments, it opens up space for things like harmony notes, for crans, for rolls, for triplets that you wouldn't otherwise be able to do.
And that's another step along then, you know, you've created that space for another kind of ornamentation.
So you can see where the, it kind of gets a bit blurred as to what, what is ornamentation and what is variation.
So yeah, so anybody else move on?
Yeah, I'll go on to a reel because it's, jigs are, I think, sometimes less fun.
Um, what, is there anything else that I was going to say?
Yeah, if you want to look at, like, so crazy variation, if you want, um, a YouTube, have you a question, Jim?
Or is your hand just up accidentally?
Exactly. Um, so, uh, if, if, uh, you want to look at, uh, variations, Tommy Potts, Ronan Brown has a series of Tommy Potts, uh, videos on YouTube.
Um, one of them is My Love Is In America, and there's all of them, they're all, like, that kind of variation is insane.
Like, you know, there's, like, he makes major tunes into minor keys, and he changes the, the time signature of things, you know?
But it is very interesting to listen to, and you can, like, to me, this is where the creativity in the music is.
And, with, if you look at videos like that, um, and hear, listen to the playing of Tommy Potts, the fireman, the fireman fiddler, um, you will really hear, like, somebody's creativity really in full flow, you know?
It's absolutely insane.
Um, but it's kind of, like, he's amazing, so he can do that.
But it's, like, oh my god, what, you know?
And I think another, I think Aidan Connolly, the fiddle player, is, uh, very interesting for variations like that as well.
Where you're kind of like, oh my god, you know?
But the, the important thing then is to be able to root yourself, in all of this, to be able to root yourself back in the tune and find the tune again.
Um, and so, it's funny that, that, uh, I, I think, I can't remember who it was, I said it at the start.
Um, oh, my touch screen isn't working.
Um, oh, Karen, I think it was, yeah.
Um, that it does kind of, um, it does kind of help to really root yourself in the tune, and that knowledge of the tune is so important.
Um, let's look at, um, like, you know, let's just have a quick interlude, before we go back to simpler variations, of a couple of crazy ones.
Like, you know, like, um, that tune.
Um, no idea what it's called.
Um, but like, there's something Michal always did in that, like, that, and I, I do, it, it suits a couple of tunes.
Like, I don't know, I can't figure out what they are, but when you get to that point, it's like what you were saying, Lulu.
When you get to that point in that tune, you're like, oh, that, that will work here.
So, basically, it's kind of funny when he goes.
Hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm.
you know it's a real mad kind of you know you know so you're really changing
up the maths the whole you're not just changing you're changing the melody for
quite some time and then getting back to it it's you know this is what I think
that these little steps that you do really set you up to be able to go in
and do more and more and of course listening to the person you want to
sound like is a good thing you know the part and what what variations they do
and that that's going to be really helpful but that again in situ
all right so I need to play the tune twice I need to play the first part twice
you know it's kind of crazy it's a crazy little air I love it though and when
you're in a session it's a really nice a nice little variety thing and so and
things I think reels I mean I have historically worked on and you know the
Sally Gardens and the has anyone been to any of these you know the Sally Gardens
the Star of Munster are really interesting tunes to work on but people
might have done those with me before I'm not sure if has anyone done those with me
before oh there's a new message let's see the scar to Glen let me look and see
what it's like dude dude scared to Glen oh that's what it is oh yeah thank you
didn't even know the name of it when it was shown to me and okay so and another
one then it's even kind of just fun to pick a tune and just see what happens
rather than have it like swinging on a gate could be a good one and let's have
a look and see oh yeah there is kind of fun things that you know swinging on it
most people seem to know swinging on a gate right so like it's I think it's kind
of a nice chamber so we've two of those and then we have so we've three C a B G's
one two three do you know what I mean so that's first step to identify the
repeating the repeating boring bit I mean here that that I think it's quite
charming that that repeated C a B G especially the two at the end that
happen close together it's kind of nice confusing for students though and
hmm sometimes there's in a chin like for me that's quite a huge feature of this
tune that little for that phrase of notes isn't it I'm not gonna go crazy
varying that like to the extent that I did with the other one
with the C a B G though I would definitely vary that so right there and
C a B G and you don't need you don't need many ways you know you just need a few
ways so that you're not doing it over and over again the same way so C a B G it's
four short notes first step let's make a long note you heard me doing it already
C B G okay now that's more interesting that opens it up in concertina for some
for some harmony notes so now maths one two three four we're in real time so now
we have the C taking up the A spot the A is gone C B G and I'll remember whatever
happened before it's staying the same and whatever after it's A G E G is staying
the same you know it's a B most of the time coming before it it could be
different no it's always a it's a B until the end and then it's a G coming
before it so and now we've C B G okay let's see what hat what's another way
because now I can play play different twice there in the end I'm actually
hearing a longer C now so this is a a little bit more of an advanced move so
you have you want to keep things the same but we want to make this C into three so
it wants to take up the the B as well so now one two three will this work will a
G work going into the A because it's an A G E G after it and so I'll play it the
normal way first or the G doesn't sound good to me there what often happens I
find is that when you take up the second spot you move it along and you you kind
of that becomes there then and so if I if I put that B in and get rid of that G
all together that because C to A is a kind of a natural fall in the scale C B A
are our natural descending things so so now I have instead of the G doesn't
sound as good that second option there the B sounds much better so now I can
play that like it's actually more interesting to play the second to like
the second four bars of it so you know and you can just play it different every
time and that's that's you can play them in different spots I don't know if
there's anything note substitution get rid of that a and replace it with a D
that's gonna work and you kind of sometimes I get my students to suggest
a note and you you might suggest it based on logic and theory and then you
go to players there's only one way to find out if it works it's going to play
it you know so C D B G definitely works and on here it is
and I think a G will work I think it would sound nice because we're in the key
of G and I think a return to a G both times will work so not only one way to
find out I think you'll agree that sounds pretty good you know and I wonder is
there any other note there's another variation that yeah like so CG worked
because we're in the key of G so G I G is gonna kind of work my G's are funny I've
been told over and over and so I mean you could also do C D back to your C B kind
of almost taken from this one from the big long C the beginning and ending the
same but the inner notes just a bit different so let's see what that sounds
like so that works too but it's just not the tune but you could get you can do
that once you know and that's fine you don't want to do it every time you don't
want to get stuck oh this is how I play it now you know that's all of them played
they're just in the second four bars of that eight bar because you but you have
the other one as well so that you know that's quite again no skill involved the
only skill and is is you know trying to figure out I'm playing around with it you
know it's that does that make sense is that of any interest or of any use to you
it's all small things looking at the key is good for that one there you know the
C G B G and that one is good for you know you kind of go okay what why would
you go back to a G that definitely works and it I know you said I'm a battering
around but is anyone another real and maybe just for the crack maybe you know
it's because that's what it's real life is like oh here's a real what how do we
you know rather than me having something prepared this is a little bit more
interesting and I hear you say the Eaton Derry say again the Eaton Derry or oh so
many yeah a lot of has a lot of um repetition in it as I recall yeah totally does so the
Eaton Derry is you know that's the first part I'm kind of going with a lot of first parts here
but that B A G and Eaton Derry I'll put some of those names up that Eaton Derry is a weird little
town in Westmeath that I I don't know if I've ever been to it and it's only up the road and so the Eaton Derry
it's the tune the repeating bit like I said just said if that's the bit you find B A G B G G B A G B A G
B A G happens three times it's similar to all of these it happens three times in four bars so six times in the first part alone you need a way to play it differently you know and so B A G B G G
first thing I do with concertina is play the B twice take up the second space with another B just yeah it's it's I don't know if it works on all instruments
you know so that's a nice easy way to break it up into its four and get the math sorted out B B A G won't work for all instruments I don't think
um and then it's kind of like you know okay well we're turning a long note into short notes so now let's you look at the note substitution so I mean
that's another thing I didn't talk about the other time if you let's look at these two B's you can sub out both of them
actually the most easy and instinctive one to sub out is the second one so a high D like we're in the key of G
now the the notes in the chord of G are G B and D one three and five so B is the third in the in the in the key
of G so G B and D so I'm gonna say that a G or a B a G or a D is also going to work here so let's write
them both down and let's hear how they sound so B D and everything stays the same after so you don't even
have to think about that and then B G a G okay so they all work you know and low D might work B D a G
maybe not as as well that one could be like weird wouldn't work in all instruments yeah not as much
uh now it's got the other option is to substitute the first one and the way that works is there's
only one way to do that you pick the note and it's probably like a slide in a whistle or a or a fiddle
maybe that you're sliding up to the note you pick the note below the main note so here we have a B
we're gonna pick the A and the second note is you landing on the main note so A B and the second
ones the other notes stay the same so now you have I'll play them true so so I'll just play the
normal and the last one just for now and you can hear it's got a different feel it's kind of like
a slide up to it like a whistle or a fiddle would do so anytime you have a long note divided into into
its two beats you can survive usually the second note has a ton of options related to the chord of
the of the key we're in and then the first one you can always do a little slide up to it and the note
below but no other note really will work there in that first position so that's kind of an interesting
one and and let me see if there's any other way so I play I play the tune just so you can you know and
that's all in one spot in the tune you can do the same to other spots you know and then suddenly you've
got far more and again not a single bit of ornamentation there or just melodic variation so
you know and I know that people are into ornamentation and a plug and I promise you that my ornamentation
website that I've been talking about for oh maybe a feckin decade at this point is actually nearly ready
to go live and at the moment it's concertina but there'll be other instruments on it too and it'll just
be all about approaching ornamentation and how to get ornamentation including melodic variation and
into your music and how to just a kind of a guide that will bring you through repetition and you know
it can be boring and then there's moments of excitement when you get it and you get used to it and so
that's it's called the ornamentation hive I'm hoping to get it online April May and so um but that's the
Eden Derry and somebody said Gehen's or the Bear Island the Bear Island
you know it's the same principles you're just trying to you've got a Bear Island is a fussy tune you know
it's it's not got repeating and phrases in that first part it's all different it's a great tune
and but you're looking for a place and it's all short notes so find a long note you know DBC a becomes D
C a becomes D D C do you know what I mean you've moved it along we did that already and before that
we we didn't so I'll just write it out quickly why not and just and again you know you don't need
to know any of these tunes the bit we're looking at is D B C a B D D and so on D that's a C sharp get
rid of the B D C A and then D we want to get rid of the C but the A is not going to work I just know
and you'll go because the next note is a B D down to C do you see these things repeat like you know
it's actually kind of boring you know like it's not once you realize once you see it you're like oh yeah
you she did that already she moved a note along got rid of that one and then it turned out that
the following note meant that the three sequences of notes are scaled downwards so that no we did
that already you know and so that kind of thing just becomes instinct because there's no way you're
going to go through it in your head every time do you know it's like it just becomes boring and
you're like but it's nice to play it you know and again that one that's held for one two three needs
to have attitude you know okay there we have a long note just turn it into short notes I think 90% of
this melodic variation thing is just long note short notes as I call it that whole system of finding
your long notes turn them in short notes find your short notes and try and create long notes you know
that's a really good baseline kind of thing to do and I don't know the beauties of autumn the Gihan's
reel I'm not sure what that is either and but I can look them up why not it's kind of fun like you know
and you can kind of try and find little little patches like that in your own tunes that you're
working on at the moment and let's see what's Gihan's it's is it Tommy Gihan let's have a look
it's I have a feeling it's a GUI is it that's how we spell Gihan over here little little dope I'll put
in G-E-E-H-A-N and see what comes up oh I won't spend too long because we're nearly at the end
I can play the first few notes
sure
oh it's Eileen O'Callaghan's is it this one
yeah I have it here hang on till I see what it is
I don't
very close
oh yeah Michal plays that one
yeah I mean it's the same thing it's the same the same theory really I maybe I won't go into it
because I'm not that sure the tune it might be just a bit of a so let's have a look like if you
if you that's the first phrase you know do do do do do do do bump up but is that that's really you know
that's it's gonna be the same thing you get yes once you see me do a few of these you're like oh
yeah this is actually really boring and G sorry G I'm surprised I can get a whole workshop out of it
B G D G B A D G B A so we have a long note we're in the key G yeah you know you can figure out how to
three ways to find out what key you're in look at the last note of a eight bar thing works 90% of
the time but not all the time and try and record yourself playing the tune play it back and try and
play a G along with it or an A along with it and if it sounds right it's probably in that key of it
sounds wrong it's probably not and if your ear is terrible god help you and and but looking at the
notes in it like you know the C naturals and the key and you know that these are all like every
single note there except the A is in the corner of G G B and D they're all you know that's so we
know where the key of G now we G B G D G B A G B so let's do the move along trick again so we did G for
two so we make it last for three that G then this is a real typical example now we have another G we
can't hold it for four I mean we can but you need serious attitude for that so that's that's a real
typical example of moving the B along you know and and more than the other ones the other two examples
that we did and if you asked me what the other two examples were I wouldn't be able to tell you now
but I know we did that twice already G B D you know and and sorry B and then this stays the same the
whole way down you know you're kind of rooting yourself so that you know where to get back to
so because or I mean the other thing that I did the first step usually is a G G you know just to
divide it into its four but I play it like I that's part of my style is to play that like a double G up
nearly all the time and and then it's it's a funny one because it's not going back to the G here it's
here so you can't do a G F G I mean you could do what I would do there is base my my little short note
very variations on this a lot of the three G taking up three notes rather than two so now I can do G F G
and stick with the B and that's going to work going back into that so that's my that's what I would
base that on so you've got do you know what I mean so whereas it would be hard to vary that too much
I needed to get this done first which is funny I didn't it it happened instinctively I didn't because
that's kind of nearly in other ones of other examples I would wait till down here before
showing you that but it's something in me knew that I had to do that in order to get any more
kind of variation so you can see how it kind of starts to you just kind of get a feel for it as
well definitely you know and start listening to to all those people and that you like whose music you
like and that you think you want to sound like you know and that's what I did if I you know I
spoon-feed my students I spoon-feed the hell out of them I'm like Jesus Christ nobody ever spoon-fed me
like this and but what I did was I for an hour or two every night I sat with me Hall O'Reilly's music
because that's who I liked and I I there was no slow down or thing it was cassette and just write
down every little thing I could hear him doing and there's no substitute for that just to go in
the what are they doing and like I didn't really ask him but like if my students ask me what did
you do there I'm so happy and I will tell them but like most hardly any of my students do that you
have to there's a few where they're like really like fully like realize that that's it like that
you have to like really toothpick fine-tooth comb not a toothpick a fine-tooth comb and go through
it and GBBG let's see yeah it's okay I wouldn't do it instinctively definitely not incorrect might
work on other instruments better than mine yeah I you could put a little cut between it then if you're
going into the ornamentation territory yeah I kind of like it that's kind of one I wouldn't have
thought of so yeah um so yeah um any questions there that's probably I mean you get the idea yeah
is it did was it all stuff you know already or did that help at all
okay good good good I hope so but um it helps to break it all down yeah I mean it's it is that's
basically what it is when you actually kind of go for it feel free to unmute there if you want to say
anything but um it's kind of you know it's there's a bit of drudgery there for sure that you have to go
through but you can see that even in the future what did we do five tunes there's repetition already
in the in the thing that we did you know uh it's instinctive for me um but you have your kind of
patterns and your you know each person has their patterns and their things they do um for sure um
it wouldn't necessarily yeah Jim so basically what we're looking for is flexibility
and not uh pre-arranged arrangements that we learned that just play those arrangements in a
non-varied way well yeah a bit of both like as children we compete in the flas and the flas is
um you arrange your flat tune so I suppose you know if you think of it like a a person born here
playing this music you know I would have arranged all my flat tunes but you're also
in sessions kind of instinctively learning it but there's definitely no harm in arranging your tunes
um but also to put in this kind of I don't know even maybe the knowledge of this might help
rather but I find with my students that it's it's the skill to be able like you're trying like that
video game analogy these obstacles coming towards you is really quite a good one for how you want your
brain to be working you know that oh oh I'm not I'm not good you know it's not wrong it's not wrong to play
and you know actually I probably the first time around the tune would play it would play it like
that you know and then start to put slight variations in and you just get kind of an instinct for it but
you have the instinct isn't enough if you're not able to react I suppose and it is kind of it is kind
of like that so the training of reacting um I think is really important and for adult learners is what I'm
really looking at you know this is more applicable to adult learners than to children really who
absorb things like feckin you know sponges curses curses of god on them all um but yeah yeah a
combination Jim I would say anybody else any questions or anything to add
yes yeah so I know the whole idea I think a lot of this is to avoid for formulas and to um um avoid
boredom and um but um um not to get a formula but how in terms of the variations and also ornaments
in playing let's say one particular tune do you have a certain um general philosophy or
um about how how you build a tune you know like you said just said you start maybe the first time
through playing it the basic you know historic notes that you learned and then how do you build it
is it just a linear progression where you yeah I build it from I mean on my instrument um you have
you know I'd be inclined to put in simple harmony notes in within the same octave of the uh of the tune
before then putting you know uh lower octave bulkier things in I would be hanging on to chords or to
crans for a while I wouldn't be too I'd be keeping them for a little bit later in the tune and I think
that's not I'm not I wouldn't be too unique in that I think that would be quite common to let the tune
breathe and then let it be delicately kind of decorated and then uh you know go create go all out
you know the third time around or whatever or towards the end kind of thing that's what I
I I'm you know I'm t any of my kids that I'm teaching um with their flat tunes that's kind of
what I'm trying to get them to do like I try to not I hate the idea that at the flat now the tune has
been arranged for them so they learn it that way I want them to I want to give them you know 10 ways
of playing that 10 ways of playing that bit there that bit there that bit there now you have all these
ways of playing that you put it together you know and I think that's really um more useful but they
they they probably won't win because I'm not make making it into this scientific project that they
just know how to do this because like I hate the fact that kids now you know a lot of them just know
this amazing flat tune in F minor and but they can't play like the silver spear you know I just hate
it it's awful um so yeah I must teach them all the silver spear this week actually I'm always saying
that and I never teach it because it's kind of hard actually on concertina but um yeah so there's
there's loads uh loads but I think really before going too crazy with any of the um ornamentation
before going too crazy with ornamentation look at what you can do with just no technique whatsoever
it's amazing you don't need you don't need to be afraid of ornamentation and thinking of oh god it's
all these techniques I have to learn I can't do it do that first get your brain doing that first
that's going to make your brain better going to make it more able to do the ornamentation when
it comes up you know and then and then you've got the world is your oyster you know and really work
on one tune find your tune that you're playing find your little bits in it that are um that are
repetitive figure out a way to play them and play it different every eight bars or four bars or two bars
or one bar when you're on one bar you're able to do it you know that would be the the kind of way I
would uh approach it hi Kathy um yeah I would approach it that way so yeah uh anybody else
well okay um so so but the the I guess also a matter of taste so the final time around on a tune
you you wouldn't necessarily it wouldn't be linear that's probably by the time you get to the last
time around the basic melody is unrecognizable and no one knows where you started from no definitely
not like I'll play that I'll play the um superman jig as if I was playing it the second time around so
you know we're kind of
you know
you know what I mean so you might
you know what I mean so you might go a little bit off piste but not crazy you
know so it's still recognized I'm you know people have different styles Tommy Potts is going to be
playing it and you're like what the hell is that Tony DeMarco you're like what's that Paul
McNevin what is what's that chin ah you're gonna know what tune I'm playing people are different
you know you're gonna know the tune you're gonna it's recognizable as that tune you know so yeah
can't say those names outside what happens in tune supply stays in tune supply
but those guys are great like that they're they've got jazz heads on them I you know that
we the rest of us can't keep up with them is basically what's happening you're like what
what is that and they're you know flying around the place so yeah I suppose we can wrap it up
there it's Sunday night I should probably relax um and uh enjoy the rest of your Sundays and
I believe that Caitlin if um I'll put my email address up there sure why not and if any of you
want to be on my concertina mailing list or on my ornamentation hive uh mailing list sure you can drop
me a line on this oh it oh I've got no um I've got no s hang on I know I just have to do the copy
pasting again I know that the tune supply password is copied and pasted there's copy okay now I can do
it so the can you take a look at my cat you should have me on your list already right Brenda I think
you yeah you're on all the lists I want to make sure yeah I think you are no you definitely are I'm
terrible with um hey Miranda Castles I'm terrible at mailing lists actually I so you won't get any
if you join this mailing list you will I guarantee you won't get any emails
say again you're one of the few people I would want an email from oh Ren I promise I'll email you
myself and Ren we uh we we track we were on the road together um because my other thing is a bus
a coach tour a Halloween themed coach tour of Ireland so we've our second one coming up in October
and uh so yeah uh it was fun it was fun it's gonna be fun again this year um all right guys any other
any other questions I'm not in a huge rush so if there's anything else at all fire it out there while
you can drop me a line nice to see yous all yeah thank you very much all faces and you lovely uh
Brenda there was one last thing I wanted to ask yeah and that is uh are there um regional traditions
with variation uh so would you be able to identify a player based on uh where he or she uh is located
or comes from or what with variation I don't know with variation with ornamentation for sure you know
that already probably but I don't know what variation I guess and probably it's it then you're
starting to go into the whole ornamentation or variation is a type of ornamentation thing you
know and then definitely yeah for sure for sure fiddle players it's mostly fiddle but the concertina
like that uh Claire concertina style the twi all the twiddly bits you know is so different than up here
in Meads really you know uh the Michal kind of style so different but yeah great thanks all right guys
a pleasure I have to say always a pleasure
see you next time
so long
you